so it is a rookie match-up
as they go head-to-head backs against
the wall for the oakland a's game three
jose or katie in this game
yeah who's been tough during the
postseason has really good numbers as
you see there 14 and a third only two
earned runs
only five starts this year as he
recovered from covet turning him today
with the ball he's going to
be for the most part fastball cutter the
occasional change-up and slider
and tommy stella coming up stella the
second baseman for the athletics
to center field and springer going back
it'll take him to the track at the wall
it's gone a home run
tommy la stella puts the oakland a's on
top one to nothing
in the first inning falls been flying
out of here and it's the a's
who get today's first home run straight
away center field for tommy la stella
jesus lozardo on the mound today for
game three with a lead before he even
took the hill today
they've entrusted with the ball this
elimination game you've seen the wild
card he got the start in game one three
and a third
six hits couple home runs but a guy
that's got a live fastball he's one down
here in the first and it brings up jose
altuve
this is driven out towards deep left
center field for altuve
and this game is tied one swing of the
bat from jose altuve and the astros tie
it up one to one
so trading solo shots and this one was a
blast to left center field for altuve
now it's the seventh time down at the
agents quarter run five times the astro
of answer
they have to find a way to get this shut
down first and third with one out a run
in
and carlos correa here's the ground ball
to third base pendrive go to second for
one on to first and it's not in time
ronald's score from third brandley comes
in and the astros
take a 2-1 lead see he's coming about
here in the top of the second inning
canna
biscotti loriano in the inning there's
an o2 that is sent out towards deep
right center field
back goes springer at the wall and that
ball is gone a home run mark canna
had five during the regular season and
he ties the game at two
so home run derby again today from
dodger stadium in l.a
a guy in the middle of the lineup
they've been waiting to get going he
gets a hanging off speed pitch
second home run given up on a off-speed
pitch up in the zone
this game is tied two to two it does
have the feel that uh two to two is not
going to be where we're gonna be for
very long
crown ball shifting but diving at first
is guriel and
over his arcade to cover and they retire
le stella this time
off speed pitch girl look at that play
gets there makes the perfect
toss turkey covering we are lucky we got
the two best defensive first basemans in
the american league playing in this
series with matt olson
and yolie gary elle and it'll be matt
olson who leads it off yoklai's fourth
inning
tied up two to two it's driven to deep
right field a towering home run to right
that is very gone to the back of the
pavilion
olson with his second home run
has put the oakland a's on top three to
two
home crushed to right wow saw john
carlos stanton do one last night in san
diego and this one
absolutely hammered first pitch up in
the zone
one down top of the order marcus simeon
coming up
simeon drives this to center field
springer going back
at the wall that ball is gone home run
for simeon
at seven during the regular season it's
home run number four of the day for the
oakland a's
and they take a 4-2 lead on four solo
home runs
unbelievable and this time it's simeon
and he knows it right away
base is filled down with oakland a's and
mark cannon is coming up
1-2 and it's luke to center field in
coming his springer
and he'll make the catch the runner on
here for the astros in the fifth let me
see diaz
standing in this is line to left struck
well
back towards the corner and that ball is
gone
a two-run home run for diaz ties the
score at four for the
houston astros a leadoff walk followed
by a two-run shot
for diaz and this game is tied four to
four on yet another home run
two on with one out and you get the
number three man coming up in brantley
line to center and that's in for a big
hit springer will be waved around
luriano's up and throwing it is cut off
run scores throw to third and they'll
get the out there about two bay
so they do get the out but coming in to
score for the astros with the fifth run
from second base is springer and it's
five for houston
and they'll bring up alex bregman to
left field and on the move is canna
headed back towards the wall and the
ball is going to be off the wall
from second comes brantley he'll score
throw to second
he is not going to be in time and the
astros take a 6-4 lead
kyle tucker coming up here for the
astros on the ground up the middle and
that'll find its way into right center
field around from second comes bregman
throw goes to third run is in and up the
second base on the throw goes tucker
it is seven of four the astros on top
now
josh james has given a back-to-back hits
to begin things here
in the seventh inning and here's chad
pinder and he drives one to right field
towards the corner tucker going back
onto the track at the wall it's gone a
three-run home run for pinder and with
one swing of the bat for the oakland a's
this game is tied seven to seven pinder
takes it out of the yard to the corner
the fifth home run of the day for the
oakland a's is a three-run home run
bushman at third loriano at second
nobody out here in the eighth
murphy lifts a fly ball to right field
over tucker
battling the sun in the sun field will
make the catch tagging at third
is grossman the throw to the plate will
be late and the oakland a's take the
lead
on top eight to seven on a sac fly by
sean murphy
and on the throw taking third base was
loriano tommy lestello the hitter here
first and third
and that one hits him painfully so if
stella goes down this will load the
bases and he is in some pain
i think he just missed that pad and got
him down on the bottom part of the elbow
he's going to come out of this game and
that's a tough
baseball player right there so the bases
are filled with athletics and you got
chat pender coming up
and it is driven in the air to right
field tucker headed over towards the
corner battling the sun
will make the catch tagging at third
base and scoring is loriano
and that will put the athletics on top
nine to seven
looks like we're going to have a pincher
coming up here reddit coming up payoff
pitch
reddick strikes out and hendricks out of
a major jam
breaks the bat as reddick strikes out so
two down and that'll bring up michael
brantley bradley will lift it in the air
to left field
as grossman wanders in he's under it and
the oakland a's
live for another day what a win for the
oakland a's